normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
vigilante gunman nabbed for shooting at
homeless wouldbe robber in New York City
subway station I want you to analyze
that headline real quick vigilante
gunman someone read it for me vigilante
gunman nabbed for shooting at homeless
would be robber in NYC subway station
and what did you notice in that headline
oh well the would be the would be yeah
because uh the story could also be
homeless man throws woman in front of
train yeah instead it's a vigilante
nabbed I love they they arrested the guy
I don't think it's wise to shoot in a
Subway don't get me wrong but it is
crazy that we are getting to this point
we've warned about it a homeless guy was
mugging a woman and trying to steal her
stuff this guy sh shouted out fired a
what he called a warning shot but I'm
not I'm not a fan of warning shots in
subways I don't think that makes sense
and and and stopped it the point is
obviously don't shoot in crowded places
like that because you don't know what's
where that Bolt's going to go and you
don't what damage is going to cause
there there's a lot of stuff down there
but more importantly it's gotten to the
point where people have started
illegally in New York City carrying guns
and they're not criminals and they're
not bad guys they're doing it because
they're scared for their safety and now
we've got the return of Subway
vigilantism you mean they're playing by
the same rules as the criminals that's
right uhhuh yep I can't think of a major
city that's like Pro 2A that has a
serious homeless population but I mean
the obvious answer is if if you had a
large homeless population but everyone
in the community including the homeless
world where people carried guns it would
be very different Nashville maybe I
guess I don't really know I don't know I
it's hard for me to I want to say yes I
feel like well because it's in Tennessee
I might think yes I don't know what
Nashville's particular law but it's that
was pretty clean I was there maybe like
three months ago oh there's Parts I
definitely have a homeless problem but
it's not like an aggressive problem like
I I've seen in parts of and if you were
in I mean like all of the cities where
you know you know crime is really rampid
especially with being perpetrated by
homeless people like I think of San
Francisco you can't carry a gun in San
Francisco what what you talking about so
in some ways wouldn't it behoove someone
in the New York State Senate to say hey
maybe we should change the gun laws in
New York so people can carry to deter
crime instead they they'll never don't
like the G don't they have a robot
police officer down there that now
patrolling the the subway oh just
imagine what that's going to be like you
know a guy comes up to you stop it a guy
comes up to you and he's like punching
you in the face and trying to grab your
purse and then the robot goes criminal
you are breaking the law please stop
stop and we finally found something more
useless than gun laws it's going to be
funny when the robot the robot will just
go whoop whoop whoop right while you're
while this guy's mercilessly beating a
woman just just push the robot in front
of a train yes yeah I'm AF I'm afraid to
give them ideas but maybe like a a door
opens with an arm to apprehend and then
put them inside like shoots tasers and
hopefully hits the right big robot you
know it's like a c it's like a giant
candy corn and it's like glass so you
can see fires a bag and then seals them
in like we should stop giving them IDE
though for sure cuz they will do that
but it's interesting they won't send
police down there they'll just send the
robot here's what I love I love the
combination of of future automated
dystopia along with the economic
collapse dystopia because it results in
homeless people destroying robots in San
Francisco they're just flipping the
machines over and smashing them and
stealing food out of them kicking the
robot dog yeah that's that's kind of a
cool future yeah I don't know I don't
know what am I supposed to say about
this they've got robots driving around
San Francisco San San Fran delivering
food
and treated Terri just flip them over
and then steal the food and leave and
there's like what are they going to do
about it there's no humans this is the
Natural Evolution of Battle Bots it is
this thing in the subway does look like
a battlebot actually yeah maybe they
need to work on the Transformer suit
then and like a person should be inside
stop giving them ideas please I want to
go straight to RoboCop where they have
the one that malfunctions we're talking
about RoboCop and Ai and IR Man suits I
think what we should be really scared
about is the Amazon stores where you can
walk skin and you don't need you just
grab whatever you want and walk out it
automatically charges you that is the
private sector basis for what will
become horrifying Robo law enforcement
yeah you think it's bad now it's like oh
who cares you walk in grab your you know
milk bread and eggs and walk out it's
convenient what do you think it's going
to be like when those things are
everywhere you go everywhere you jwalk
you get a ticket in the mail yeah y
that's crazy that's crazy to me and also
how the way you started this by looking
at the title like the the way they Bend
reality is what's terrifying to me right
like they could have written this
headline so many different ways you know
and like that that does frame people's
perception clearly like the uh the other
day when the guy was killed in uh
California at the protest you know he
died in the street and then he was a
dead guy whatever they made it sound
like he fell or whatever elderly man
falls and hit head dies right they frame
these realities that are so crazy this
is that right then people you know a lot
of people don't have the time to we talk
about all the time right A lot of people
just read the post but this is the same
here's a headline for you VI vigilante
gunman who saves woman's life from
attempted robbery arrested for firing
gun it should just be man arrested after
defending self in subway from no no he
didn't defend himself defending like
someone else
ien
again problem I have no problem with the
headline saying he opened he fired a gun
in in the subway you should not do that
that's a problem right for sure for sure
I don't mind that they identify him as
someone who shot a gun my problem is
nabbed makes it seem like he was the
problem when there is
homeless person robbing someone on the
subway like man intervenes fires gun
during attempted robbery you know what I
mean like it there are other ways to do
it except the first three words in this
are saying this is who you should be
framing as the villain it's a negative
connotation V vigilante gunmen it's like
the bad people the people with guns who
are defending themselves and defending
others I just want to say this is the
New York Post and they are famous for
one of the best headlines ever headless
body and topless bar yeah yeah wow class
we'll bring that back because it's way
better what whatever's happening right
now we're almost there again with this
world that they're creating and is this
the same paper that thought Nikki Haley
won last night cuz wouldn't make sense
with new perceive reality gu who want
debate Nikki Haley and I was like I know
she didn't a New York Post alert not a
New York Post I'll have to look at it
but I got like a news alert on my phone
being like who won last night's debate
Nikki Haley just in case you didn't no
questions she won sure wow wow and if
you didn't if you if you watched it
you'd just be like huh it's crazy they
can't control reality anymore
is anyone watching the debates though
because I think Trump's up like 50
points or something yeah you know who
won last night's debate Trump as per
usual yeah yeah have more viewers yep
I'm concerned that he does get the
nomination and then he ends up getting
arrested you can't run maybe they go
after the 14th they say you can't run
who they going to put in last minute
they've had no air time no screen time
it's going to be an absolute mess well
Minnesota recently said that um they're
not keeping Trump off like they're not
going to during the primaries M right
now trial cforia so the issue is this
the states do not have the right to
determine eligibility only the federal
government does which means any lawsuit
to remove Trump from the from the
federal elections could not be done at
the state level it needs to be done at
the federal level and the federal
government needs to make the
determination and they already did with
the impeachment trial for which Trump
was acquitted so uh the way it's
supposed to work constitutionally is if
a president does something wrong they
are impeached and tried if convicted
they are then criminally potentially if
they want to pursue it then criminally
indicted and and and and tried again in
this instance uh uh Trump was acquitted
wasn't even wasn't even wasn't even uh
uh uh convicted in the impeachment trial
he was impeached but not removed yeah so
it should be done but they're going to
do it anyway because it's partisan I
like the Minnesota ruling because the
judges said there's no there's nothing
in under state law that says that we can
say someone can't participate in a
primary and then you know you guys have
to decide on the federal level if this
is if if you have the ability to take
him off from the general election I
think it is really good that our system
is set up where there are steps and
there's power at the state level and
power at the federal level because
that's the only way to keep it from
being like well Colorado said can't be
on there's the Colorado ruling is not in
but you know this one state did
something so now we all have to obey it
I think it's good to have the
differentiation and I'm glad that the
Minnesota ruling came out first sure I
don't think Colorado matters as much
but uh one state taking his name off and
that's going to spike the popular vote
count for him which could lead to Crazy
turmoil in this
country could like he could has anyone
won before with
ryen I don't know I'm assuming to a
certain degree maybe there's a whole
campaign right now to get to do a
writing campaign in New Hampshire
primary because Biden didn't register to
be on the ticket because Biden and the
DNC are saying no New Hampshire's not
going first this year South Carolina is
wait wait wa wait Biden's not on the
primary in New Hampshire they Biden's
gone he's not running yeah well their
whole thing is it has to be South
Carolina First this has like been this
is kind of complicated but it's it's
been a ploy for a little while they want
the the DNC and the B and the Biden
Administration wants South Carolina to
be the first state in the nation to have
their primary because they're saying
it's better for diversity whatever else
uh Biden got wrecked in New Hampshire
when he ran last time but he won South
Carolina by 26 points so shortly after
he took office this became the campaign
and so because the DNC formally decided
that South Carolina's going first this
is not true for Republicans it's very
weird year um they are New Hampshire
says no we're going first South Carolina
says but the DNC said we're going first
and so Biden said well I'm I'm not going
to register to be on the ballot in New
Hampshire because South Carolina's going
first I mean it is a bizarre everyone
says that the right is fractured but I
think the right is just a more of a
mosaic anyways there is obvious
disagreement whereas Democrats try to
operate like they're a monolith but they
are fracturing in so many different ways
I mean the Democrats in New Hampshire
are extremely upset about Los losing
potentially losing first in the nation
primary and their specific thing is
you're opening the door for Republicans
to spend more money here and convert
more voters it's very very weird I
highly recommend looking into this it's
119 and I was told something was
supposed to happen today all the weird
conspiracy theorists were like 119 what
happens now I don't know the que thing I
don't know reverse you have an
announcement to make over there 119 is
when Trump won in
2016 interesting yeah wasn't it I don't
know wasn't that the day that he won the
election 2016 I'm not sure maybe
something did happen we don't know yet
we've been sucked into a well we're busy
we're podcast we don't even know
somebody let us know this breaking news
did someone turn on the large hron
collider today have we've been sucked
into the sphere of strangeness once
again like we keep right it it was the
election was November 8th and it went
into November 9th and concluded with
Trump winning on November 9th there's
always a q Theory coming out we were
talking about downstairs it's this
wasn't a q Theory though this a
numerology the world's going to end in 5
years then five years happens and the
Colts are Jesus is coming back and then
the queue is old Trump is still
president wait you know about the red
heer I think I watch your podcast in
this one yeah yeah there was a Jerusalem
Post uh there was a forward.com article
and they were just like the red heer's
been born and that signifies the coming
of the Messiah or something like that I
don't know anything about it I just read
at some article and that was a month
before the Hamas attack yeah yeah but
what if they just Clon some thing and
died trying I know they're engineering
the end times yes but they can't so so
people are actually trying to
genetically engineer the red heer but it
has to have no it's not they many these
people believe they're supposed to bring
about the prophecy not wait for it right
accelerate it and and but no but I I
reject this this the the the the idea
that prophecy only ever was something to
wait for is made up by made up these are
people who are like if it says this must
be done it's a to-do list not a wait for
list but the problem is can't do it yeah
even when they selectively breed the the
heers the cows it ends up with blemishes
and so they're trying and it's been it's
been what like thousands of years or
whatever they've not been able to do it
but why don't they invent some like skin
care for it and see if they can it's got
to be naturally because these people
genuinely believe that you have to breed
it they're not trying to convince a
carnival right they're trying to find
something that they believe is
signifying the coming of the Messiah so
it was reported in September that they
did and now they have to wait for it get
a little older and then they're going to
check it for blemishes and this happens
a lot and then they say ah there it is
it's got a Mark it's not it's not a pure
red heer and but if it's not it has to
be sacrificed and the fear is if someone
claims that this is a pure red heer
again not an expert I read one article
then they will have to sacrifice this
for the start of the Third Temple or
whatever which will put them at odds
with Islam or something so I don't know
enough about it all I know is a lot of
people who you don't have to believe
what they believe to be worried about a
bunch of people who F yeah fighting and
causing problems because they might
believe something waiting on the on the
next do Lama remember that one kid they
they believe there the next one and then
didn't CH him right China doesn't know
and then they also declar their own
Dolly llama so it's impossible to say
what happened to the first one but they
chosen one well it's the one that China
thinks is right though you can't can't
question it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim .c for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time